this is a production of cornell
university
we've been very lucky on fishkill farms
not to
have any severe effects from the big
storms of
last year
but our neighbors have certainly had a
lot of trouble across the river in
ulster county there was uh tremendous
damage and it's not only from
the irene uh
storm and the hurricanes it was also
there have been wind and hail events
throughout the last couple of years that
have periodically caused
and the october snowstorm um knocked
over a lot of trees as well so and broke
a lot of branches
so yes there have been quite a few
events
um
that are quite severe and we're seeing
you know big swings on the
the rainfall side as well between
drought and
prolonged periods of of uh extreme
uh extremely heavy rainfall
i think as an orchard we're very well
vulnerable we have
our our whole livelihood is on the line
as a
as a fruit farm
we
have a lot of crop that is dependent on
the blossom occurring at the right time
pollination
not having
severe hail events during the
growth of the fruit crop and then
finally
not there not being too much wind
during the final harvest pre-harvest
period
so that the crop remains on the trees
until it's ripe so yes there's a
tremendous risk
throughout and that's not to mention
diseases and all the other
downsides we've been lucky with the
vegetable crop for the reason that we
produce multiple successions of the same
crop so
um we're marketing in the
farmers markets and locally here on the
farm and
planting you know every two weeks
there's a there's a new crop going in
the ground
that means that we're spreading our risk
quite dramatically
we also have some other
bed shaping and soil working
techniques that seem to avoid
us getting into a situation where we
can't
get into the
land and produce a crop
so far
we we are gradually planning to deal
with uh erratic weather events um the
biggest thing that we've done so far is
to
put in an irrigation system
they will
you can see around here
the
drip lines that are laid on the ground
with the small trees
we actually succeeded last year in
putting in
a
system that has the potential to
irrigate the entire farm
once we have all the blocks
hooked up to it and and the drip tape
laid down in the orchard we're also
gradually putting in a trellis system
that will help
support the small trees we're going to a
more dense
format for the orchard
we have
diversified water sources for our
irrigation
for the same reason that we have so much
rainfall variability
so we do draw from a small creek we have
several ponds
and
and a couple of wells and
in addition to the irrigation
using
this is now more effects the the
greenhouse the vegetable operation but
we're using greenhouses
to
balance for example with the tomatoes
rather than having
our entire tomato crop out in the field
we're putting a portion of it in a
greenhouse
to balance that
and then for the first time
this coming year we will
grow some small fruit
in
a high tunnel so high tunnel looks a lot
like a greenhouse
it's not heated this is the difference
it's not heated
and it's really
a
three season
or even two season but really a three
season uh cover to regulate
uh number one temperature variation and
number two
uh
water or rainfall
so that we can
make sure that the crop for example with
small fruit and cherries is a good
example
regulate
the
water the amount of water that the crop
gets and prevent
um in so doing prevent
the
fungus problems that one would
ordinarily have with those with those
cherries
so from a from a farming point of view i
think the most valuable information we
could get from cornell
is uh on varieties that will be adapted
for the next
20 years
of you know climatic variations
that would be best adapted as we're
planting new
blocks out every every season
an issue that is perhaps most critical
in the whole
issue of adapting to climate change and
that is
management and it's not just
what the choices of what you plant and
how you farm it's also
improving management strategies
and and
keeping a closer control on everything
that you do on the farm record keeping
being very precise apartments
activities
i think that
certainly our
our focus is how we can manage
with what we have
we we're producing a crop a variety of
crops for a fabulous market in new york
city there are lots of people who need
to eat
and
and we're lucky with our location
so
what we're interested in doing is
is adapting to whatever comes our way
and making sure we can manage through
that
we don't feel like as one
farm operation we can necessarily
influence the
the climate change itself we'd rather
manage
the effects that we're feeling
yeah
so on the question of
of whether
climate change is uh
caused by
human influence human activity or not
we
feel like it's
that's not a concern that we are going
to
address here on the farm we are very
much more interested in addressing the
effects of the climate change and
what we can do to
to deal with it
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu